oui j'ai un gros coup de gueule je me
dis pourquoi rien contre carroll mais
contre ses émissions vous savez ce but
fut comment il ya pas très longtemps
ça te fait cambrioler envoyons il n'y a
pas très longtemps la police m'a dit
vous n'imaginez pas le mal le mal que
toutes ces émissions nous font
aujourd'hui tous les mecs qui viennent
savent qu'il faut couper leur portable
parce qu'on peut les retrouver
il ya des caméras dehors enfin il faut
pas mettre les mains non non non non non
non on a fait le plein de choses qu'il
faut pas mettre les mains à tel endroit
qu'il faut pas ils savent tout tout tout
grâce à ses émissions et savent
maintenant comment on fait des double
plaque
comment l'eau qu'on doit boire ou quoi
pour pas avoir un faux pas pour pas
passer à l'alcoolémie et machin la
drogue quand est-ce que ça passe on leur
enseigne tout alors les vrais caïds le
savait mais les petits caïds qui sont
sur l'autoroute et qui rebours est où je
ne savais pas ça ils me disent vous
n'imaginez pas le mal que ça nous créé
ils donnent tous les trucs à l'antenne
alors non mais alors je vous vient
exhortons cambriolages monde y vient de
se faire filmer et les policiers ils
saturent notamment ils n'ont pas le
choix ils détestent ça c'est les préfets
qui acceptent de la fin du 2 e n'ont pas
le choix moi et mon niveau ce
cambriolage les mecs avaient vu qu'il y
avait quatre caméras devant tout a été
fait ça personne ne le savait avant
caméra thermique la caméra si vous
n'avez qu'une caméra dans les rues sur
les rues de l'émission ou alors dans les
rues ou libres de vie qu'ils ont mis des
gants ils ont tous fait il est souvent
tu étais pas vu couper leur moral parce
qu'ils savent très bien maintenant et sa
grâce aux émissions des pardons du coup
je le redis je fais une connerie avec le
portable quand on veut s'il avait laissé
lui mais on aurait pu savoir où il était
à ce moment-là tout ça c'est l'épreuve
et moi j'avoue que j'ai appris aussi
regardant ça ils m'ont dit c'est un
massacre pour nous ainsi les
professionnels c'est la famille benhaim
mais que toile apprennent des choses sur
le cambriolage en gardant cette émission
je peux l'entendre
enfin que les gens qui émettent au point
des cambriolages apprennent des choses
sur les émissions franchement je
t'arrête tout de visite parce qu'on est
bien d'avoir un appel ils vous attendent
au puy du fou le proviseur
max la raison que n'est pas que les
cambrioleurs de ça parce que les petits
les petits les petits voyous même
scénario louise après les mamelles pas
qu un litige c'est raymond qui opérait
maladie là il a raison c'est vrai que
tata prendre des petites magouilles
t'attendais tu à prendre des petites des
merdes ça n'a pas tort la route aussi ça
c'est ça c'est embêtant mais à son à ce
compte là tu fais plus faites entrer
l'accusé
tu fais plus nos modules et tu fais plus
rien d'un dangereux sur une tendance qui
dit sur le fait que les policiers les
gendarmes soient obligés en quelque
sorte de se faire filmer est totalement
absurde
il cherche ça avec leurs proches
hiérarchie palais aurait fait non je
fais quatre émissions induites
maintenant c'était la tradition j'ai
refait ma désigner les périodes
la brigade fluviale qui serait filmé qui
nous lie à messam sg qui parle toujours
de ce que tu connais pas c'est une
manière de mettre en valeur leur travail
de sape d'être populaire par rapport aux
téléspectateurs c'est très alors on va
voir un autre extrait l'aura vu un homme
pas contents de voir les gendarmes
interpellaient son fils regarde et il
aura mis un gros coup de pression mais
soudain raconte le père du jeune homme
arrive nous on est des casses couilles
en bas ou dédicace comme je ne sais pas
moi vous venez venez nous casse cou il a
fallu casser les menaces majeures avant
ils m'ont cassé les couilles avec nos
collègues c'est pas nul mais thébaux et
messieurs vous avez rien à faire son
contrôle
c'est pas des petits jeunes tombent ce
qui va faire la loi au guatemala aller
mieux goût la loi vous êtes sûr on a
connu mieux vous là il n'en a fourni un
petit concours et j'y tiens
mais passionnant que puisse de phm a
appelé autres il faut pas tuer sinon je
te jure que la tête je dois y met en
place dans chaque match et là bas vous
avez des candidats est prête à à bayonne
avec la police oui oui oui j'aurai je
respecte tout le monde savait mathieu je
respecte les hall à la police ce moment
je respecte tout le monde mais là